Joe Castiglione with the call on WEEI
step to the right the pitch swinging a
do I drive left-field Ben and Teddy
coming on dives and then he make the
catch he did he got it head over heels
in my chair oh wow what a catch by
Andrew been intending and Joe
Castiglione the Red Sox broadcaster kind
enough to join us how you feeling today
Joe very good we talked about fasten
your seat belt saves and and that was
one but it was an absolutely amazing
play and there's Red Sox outfield is the
best defensive outfield I think baseball
has ever seen okay
we'll get to that in a moment but what
happens on the call that you go head
over heels well it was a very tense
moment you know you your body tenses up
and I made the call and I went to back
up in the chair with the wheels on it
and the chair went one way and and I
stood where I was but there was no chair
there anymore underneath we just stayed
with the call Joe but the we bounced
right back up and it was a time as I
said you should always have your
seatbelt fastened especially intense
games like that anything ever happened
like that before no that's the first in
36 years of Red Sox baseball yeah I've
never seen a game end on a catch like
that certainly of this magnitude and you
know he was incredible because Josh
Reddick made he catch the safe two or
three runs in the top of the inning a
very similar play if he doesn't make
that catch though Joe
I get the feeling with two outs and Kemp
on first is off and running the Red Sox
could have easily lost that game he got
by him certainly a no question about it
but Benny did say that he saw he got
jammed a little bit and the ball hung up
and these outfielders are fearless they
have great speed they have great
reaction a very good jumper what
all that I and it was hooking a little
bit away from him
and but he just laid out we've seen him
do it time after time and the biggest
moment he made the play that's the way
these young guys to been what did you
think of the fan interference call
initially well initially I thought that
was fair game when you go into the
stands and it was very hard to tell the
fan reached over the yellow line there
would have been one really good side
shot except the security guy got in the
way but it was a definitive call by Joe
West and the more I see it the more I
think Joe got it right
Mookie told us after the game on our
postgame show he definitely would have
caught that part he really felt that he
had it lined up and he would have made
the play and you know Danny it's amazing
it was Joe West because he has been
involved so many huge plays in Red Sox
history 2004 he was the umpire at second
base when Dave Roberts had the biggest
steal in baseball history in Game six
there was a line drive by Bellhorn with
two men on the left field the left field
umpire rule doubled the ball hit the fan
in the chest bounced on the field Joe
West overruled
they called it a home run and then there
was the play at first base where a rod
slept the ball out of Roxanne's Royals
Hanna rolled down the line and Joe West
was the one who overturned the call and
ruled a rot out or interference and the
here he is in another huge Red Sox
moment he probably got to get a standing
ovation next time he goes to Fenway well
he should you know he likes to be in the
middle of things and he gets there is
number two with most games on fire at
all time but he has a special place with
us in New England because he's very
generous to the Jimmy Fund it's really
helped decide on that Jimmy Fund radio
telethon it's also when I don't know of
a team that was this good for an entire
season that came into the postseason as
maybe an underdog and and certainly an
underdog you know with the Yankees and
an underdog here with the Astros it
feels like how surprised are you that
they're sort of not
looked at as dominating well I thought
they should have been considered better
than the Yankees or the Astros it's
pending champions and that's
understandable because they have more
seasoned veterans in many ways but I am
surprised that this team to 108 games
wasn't considered the best team in
baseball because I went in thinking that
they were and I think it wasn't just by
partiality or that of Red Sox Nation
because this team has everything it has
power at his speed it's the most
athletic team we've ever had and it's
the best offensive team the quest some
of the questions were regarding the
bullpen and the setup guys have just
been outstanding this whole series brian
brazier matt barnes joe kelly
and that's been a huge difference in
this series and now you got david price
how confident are you price on the road
well I think these guys spent a beauty
here as our old manager Joel Morgan
would say he's I think he was ready to
pitch last night and he did get hot I
don't know how much that'll affect him
in the bullpen but I think he can put
that behind him and come out and and
pitch well here and I think it's a good
spot for he pitch very well against
Houston last year out of the bullpen six
and two third scoreless innings in the
division series and he probably won't go
too deep into the game considering that
he did warm up twice last night and
they'll need the bullpen it's going to
be a tough task with Verlander but I
think David you certainly pitch well
enough to keep the Red Sox in the game
are you gonna have a seat belt on
tonight Joe thank you for joining us and
good luck tonight well thank you Dan we
love your show thank you that's Joe
Castiglione for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
you
[Music]